we begin the day with a deadly crackdown
in kazakhstan that is looking more and
more like a major strategic victory for
the kremlin tonight russian soldiers are
in the central asian republic allegedly
there as peacekeepers they were invited
this week after protests over high gas
prices low wages and government
corruption turned violent with
kazakhstan's president authorizing
police to shoot without warning
in the largest city almaty demonstrators
set the city hall on fire and seize the
airport dozens of anti-government
protesters have died hundreds more are
injured police say that 13 officers were
killed in what has quickly become the
biggest crisis in kazakhstan since it
gained independence 30 years ago
today the government said for the most
part order has been restored now
president tokayev is blaming the unrest
on what he calls bandits terrorists and
militants
terrorists continue to damage state and
private property and use weapons on
citizens
i have ordered law enforcement agencies
and the army to shoot to kill
without warning
we are dealing with armed and trained
bandits both local and foreign
i repeat their bandits and terrorists
therefore they need to be destroyed
i would like to express my special
gratitude to president vladimir putin of
russia
he reacted very promptly and most
importantly in a friendly manner to my
appeal
well for years kazakhstan has been
walking a geopolitical tightrope between
the east the west and russia
kazakhstan's location makes it a bridge
between those fast-growing markets of
china and south asia
as well as russia and europe as a major
oil and gas exporter kazakhstan has
enjoyed strong economic ties with the
united states and the european union
could that now be in jeopardy with the
russian troops in the country is
kazakhstan now beholden
to the kremlin
well my first guest tonight is ben ares
he's a long time correspondent in moscow
and founder of the media company bne
intel news he joins me tonight from
right here in berlin ben it's good to
have you on the program let me ask you
has
this equation has it changed is
kazakhstan now forever in debt to the
kremlin for coming to the rescue this
week
um yes and no uh i mean to take you
through i mean it's been an
extraordinary week the events in
kazakhstan are unfolded i'm president
right the whole thing came out of
nowhere at the weekend last week uh when
there were protests in the the western
regions over these these price hikes of
fuel for cars but that spread to the
rest of the country by tuesday
and then the government quickly came in
and addressed the economic demands of
the protesters and reintroduced price
subsidies but that didn't work by by
wednesday the protests morphed into a
sort of general anti-government movement
and that point then uh
the president up the stakes and he went
from calling the the protesters
demonstrators to calling them hooligans
and said what they were doing is illegal
and he took the the riot troops went out
to the streets and tried to take the
situation back in control but by the end
of wednesday it was clear that the
government was losing control and that
that was the point that they they turned
to russia or rather to the csto this uh
joint cooperation and security
organization that they set up the sort
of eurasian equivalent of nato and asked
for help um at which point the russians
agreed to send along with the other five
members four members
agreed to send troops which arriving
this morning
and what we're seeing now is the with
the arrival of the troops the situation
has changed again the government seems
to be back in control but now there's
the follow through the cleanup operation
where they're cracking down where
they've ordered shoot to kill in order
to bring the protest to a quick end and
let me ask you as far as vladimir putin
is concerned do you think he is
we know that he can be an opportunist if
he's seizing on the unrest
and sending his troops in to expand his
influence in this country
now it's more to do with the last thing
the kremlin wants to see is yet another
color revolution there was one a year
ago in kyrgyzstan next door um where the
the alliances the friends i mean you
have to understand that russia is is
deeply invested into kazakhstan that it
has um business um ties with it the
russian companies are invested in there
in oil business and the pipelines run
out kazakhstan through russia which
earns money from that and buys the oil
and so
all said and done
putin does not want to see another color
revolution a sort of democratic
government put in here and takayev is a
partner their longtime partner and that
he um he
his concern is to rescue
have to keep stability to keep the
relations they already have rather than
territory expansion and nor will they
leave troops there i think once uh once
the order is restored now you've said
you know the events happened so quickly
this week um do you think all of this
caught both
you know the u.s nato as well as russia
off guard i mean it seems you know you
named kyrgyzstan there's also been
ukraine there's been belarus it seems
they have been sucking all of the oxygen
for the past months
yeah i mean of course everybody was by
surprise i mean this came out of nowhere
i mean the the the march is the protest
that we saw in rmit
on tuesday are unprecedented tens of
thousands of people and there's been
low-level protests been going on for
years particularly when the elections
when the old president nazarbayev left
and takaya took over in 2019 there were
protests but they quickly smothered and
the people are arrested and given
administrative 15 days in jail and let
out again but this this is off the scale
and it came from nowhere and so
everybody scrambled in order to try and
catch up
particularly the government trying to
regain control and the kremlin when
asked acted very quickly because
likewise they don't want to see another
after ukraine particularly after belarus
russia which is a huge pain in the neck
for russia they don't want to see
another long protracted demonstration
pro-democracy democracy demonstration
again
journal it's been ours giving us
valuable context of the situation in
kazakhstan tonight ben we appreciate
your time and your insight thank you
nato leaders met today to discuss the
situation as we were discussing on
ukraine's border with russia where
moscow is massing thousands of troops
officials and capitals from washington
to berlin and kiev fear that russian
president vladimir putin could be
preparing an invasion after ukraine
kazakhstan joins the list of countries
where putin is trying to flex his
military muscles earlier today our
brussels correspondent terry schultz
tried to pick the brains of native
secretary general ian stoltenberg she
asked him how he thinks russia's
intervention in kazakhstan fits into the
geopolitical puzzle that putin is
piecing together in the kremlin here's
what he said
i will not speculate
on
in what way the developments in
in in kazakhstan will impact
calculations by
or in moscow i think the main message on
on kazakhstan is that violence must stop
we have seen the loss of lives and
and human rights must be respected and
that also
includes freedom of expression and
peaceful demonstration
all right and my colleague now terry
schultz she is in brussels
terry it's good to have you on the show
again and happy new year to you let me
ask you
stoltenberg
it's refusing to stick his head out of
the window it seems with with his answer
is there a
kazakh connection here
i wasn't really surprised brent that uh
stoltenberg wouldn't take the bait on
offering me some free analysis there it
is press conference because there really
isn't a direct connection between nato
and kazakhstan um i would say there's
sort of a cordial relationship but but
nothing too involved and so nato really
won't want to be getting involved
in commenting on kazakhstan i think what
everyone's looking at now is what this
will do to the kremlin's behavior
whether president putin will be
distracted now by what's happening in
kazakhstan a country that has always
been quite stable and following a
positive line toward russia whether this
will distract him from what he's doing
in ukraine and then that of course could
have an impact on nato did you get the
impression that nato was maybe called
off guard by what has happened so
quickly in kazakhstan
i think certainly as ben eris explained
everyone was caught off guard by how
quickly the
developments in kazakhstan occurred
anyone who's looked at this country or
countries in this region knows that
there is a lot of resentment building up
for for decades among some segments of
the population so it's not surprising
that the resentment was there but that
it gained so much power in such a short
time i think did take everyone by
surprise and probably president putin as
well and again that's what everyone
wants to know what will president putin
do will he devote more of his resources
to helping settle the ground in
kazakhstan and what will that mean for
his continuing build up on the border
with ukraine yeah and you know as i
mentioned earlier today's meeting was
called to discuss the situation with
ukraine here's a little bit more of what
the nato secretary general had to say
nato will engage in dialogue with russia
in good faith
and on substance
but we must also be prepared
for the possibility
that diplomacy will fail
so today ministers
stressed that any further aggression
against ukraine would have significant
consequences and carry a heavy price for
russia
now terry if i'm hearing that right
there seems to be some doubt coming from
stoughton berg that this crisis can be
solved through diplomacy is he preparing
the ground for a possible
failure been some developments in recent
days most notably the the plan for us
and russia uh the u.s and russia to have
their meeting on monday and then for
russia to actually come to nato for
discussions next wednesday that's a big
deal because nato's been asking for
these consultations for more than 18
months and russia has always refused now
it will come to the table with ukraine
as the central topic for those talks but
certainly no one believes that diplomacy
is going to have an easy path and nato's
military planners were given orders back
in december formally to start preparing
military scenarios for the possibility
that russia does go ahead militarily and
and makes further
further inroads into ukraine or
certainly threatens nato allies and
brent tonight there's also a development
uh a report coming out of the united
states nbc news we must give credit
there that says the u.s may be
considering offering to russia as part
of its uh its hopes for reciprocity on
backing down on the border with ukraine
that u.s troops may be reduced in europe
and that's something that i've already
been speaking with people about that is
certainly not coming as any reassuring
sign to european allies here
yeah that that is a new development to
any talk about reducing the numbers of
u.s troops in europe
let's stick with the topic of the number
of troops and the russian buildup along
its border with ukraine we know that
this buildup continues so tonight based
on what you're reporting how real then
is the danger of a russian invasion
i think that the the possibility of a
russian invasion hasn't changed so much
but the capability to do so continues to
grow tonight secretary general
stoltenberg and other uh officials i
spoke to off the record today said that
it very definitely continues that russia
has not paused despite moves toward
diplomatic discussion with the u.s and
with nato it has continued to build up
in a significant way its capabilities
for an invasion should president putin
decide to do so at the same time
everyone says they really don't know if
those are the kremlin's plans yeah and
if it is true that the u.s is talking
about reducing its troop numbers in
europe that will of course catch nato
leaders completely off guard blindside
that's not going to help unity within
nato dw's terry schultz with the ladies
tonight in brussels as always terry
thank you
you